حسنًا ومن آثار المصب
لصعوبة الحصول على الاختبارات المنزلية
الآن هو عودة
لعبة الصالون التي كانت منتشرة
في بيتي أه هو
البرد أم كوفيد
فماذا؟  ما هي الإرشادات التي يمكنك أن تعطيها
للأشخاص الذين يسألون أنفسهم أنه
عندما لا يتمكنون من وضع أيديهم عليها
في الاختبار على الفور ،
هناك بعض الأشياء التي
آمل أن يفكر فيها الناس
قليلاً حول مخاطر التعرض الخاصة بك إذا
كنت  قد تكون تعرضت لشخص
مصاب بفيروس كوفين 19 ، فهذا يزيد من
احتمالية أن يكون مطمعًا 19. ولكن
للتأكد من أننا نعلم جميعًا أن الأعراض
نوعًا ما تبدو وتشعر بنفس الطريقة التي
تعاني بها من سيلان الأنف
والتهاب الحلق والسعال  واه
والصداع ، أود أن أنتبه إلى
شيئين على الرغم من أنه على الرغم من
أنه من غير المحتمل أن
تفقد حاسة الشم أو
حاسة التذوق لديك ، فهذه الأشياء خاصة بالفعل لـ
covid19 والثاني يبدو أنه  كن
أكثر قليلا  يعتبر أمرًا شائعًا مع omicron نظرًا لأن
البيانات
تمثل صداعًا ، وبالتالي إذا كنت في
موقف ربما تكون قد
تعرضت فيه ، فمن الجدير الرجوع إلى الوراء
والسؤال فعليًا عن سؤال الأشخاص الذين
كنت معهم هل كان هناك اختبار إيجابي
هناك وبمجرد أن تبدأ  الشعور بهذه
الأعراض حتى لو كانت إنفلونزا أكثر برودة
نظرًا لهدف تسطيح المنحنى ،
فمن الجدير عزل نفسك وإجراء
اختبارين ،
النقطة المهمة الأخرى هنا هي عدم الاختبار
فورًا بعد
تعرضك للإصابة ولكن بمجرد أن تحصل على
تظهر عليك الأعراض التي تريد اختبارها يومًا ما
ثم الاختبار مرة أخرى في اليوم التالي أه فقط
للتأكد من أنك معزول ولكن من
المحبط أن
تفكر في أنه موسم الأعياد
ونحن مسؤولون عن التعامل  مع
البرد والأنفلونزا في هذا الوقت من العام على
أي حال